la reducción del gas es por un fallo
técnico como dice rusia o es una
herramienta de presión política como
alega europa
mire mar y aclara yo creo que no es una
cuestión de naturaleza técnica yo
considero que en este momento de la
confrontación en ucrania gusta rusia
está haciendo pesar su capacidad de
disuasión energética puesto que al
alargarse la guerra y estar cerca al
invierno rusia sabe que de alguna manera
puede jugar esta carta es un arma en el
manos de rusia no por lo tanto yo creo
que el hecho de anunciar fíjense que es
el solo anuncio de reducir el flujo de
gas
a europa alemania que comienza este
miércoles ya hizo subir el precio del
gas de manera que para europa esto está
significando entrar en una zona de
inquietud lo que explica incluso que la
comisión europea esté pensando en
suavizar su plan de
reducción del uso del del gas por parte
de los países de europa puesto que esto
de alguna manera está implicando un
principio de catástrofe energética
económica para europa europa nos quiere
que predomine finalmente un modelo
hungría es decir que los distintos
países cada uno de los 27 países
establezca a su modo el tipo de relación
que va a tener con rusia y nor swing uno
no es el único gasoducto con el que
rusia provee gas a la unión europea
cuéntanos entonces por qué profundiza la
crisis
mire la cuestión del gasoducto nord
stream en particular es un tema más
político que energético puesto que mayo
político si se quiere energético puesto
que esto implicó un cambio de escala
para europa en particularmente para
alemania alemania no está interesada en
esta ruptura energética con con rusia
puesto que allí la distancia no
solamente es muy menor para el flujo del
jr del gas sino que el transporte del
gas por el ducto ampliado nos unen los
refrendos e implica una transferencia de
gas del territorio al territorio esto
implica evitar cualquier consecuencia
derivado de por derivadas de políticas
de terceros ucrania polonia excepto las
posibilidades de utilizar otro otro
gasoducto bueno son posibles para europa
allí aparece azerbaiyán no es cierto
como la posibilidad de utilizar el
gasoducto del sur que nos pasa por
territorios de rusia pero bueno estos
son tratativas lo que hasta ahora les ha
bastado y le importa la europea es
evitar
puesto que no todos los países de europa
están interesados en que se reduzcan su
consumo de gas por ejemplo españa no
está interesada pero si otros otros
países si los afectan